[Music]
it won't be long before the time finally
arrives and we are once again able to
immerse ourselves into the world of
middle earth and the story surrounding
the rings of power unlike the famous
film trilogy by peter jackson the amazon
series does not revolve around the
destruction of sauron's one ring but
around the original story of how the
mighty rings came to be some teasers and
trailers have already given us a little
preview of what the most expensive
series of all time might be about
therefore we have taken the time to sum
up everything you need to know about the
cast the plot as well as the production
the plot of the rings of power takes
place around 3000 years before the rings
in the hobbit trilogy at this point in
time is the early second age in middle
earth however it can also be assumed
that the first stage is at least dealt
with in flashbacks the second age opens
with the victory of the valar over
morgoth the primordial source of evil
and master of sauron during this time
there are no rings yet and even their
creator sauron is still of little
importance in middle earth thus his rise
will certainly be the focus of the
action also middle earth is still much
more mystical than in the age of men who
are still a very young race here balrogs
are far more than just legendary figures
and the all-powerful spirit beings
called valar still have a role to play
in world events
the cast list is very long which is why
we will only discuss actors whose parts
are already known of course we will also
stumble upon names that are familiar to
us from the other six films however the
makers have also allowed themselves a
certain degree of artistic freedom and
created some characters that do not
originate from tolkien
a large part of the cast is made up of
the elves in the second age they start
to expand further in middle-earth and
establish new kingdoms such as a region
a region is founded by galadriel and her
husband celeborn the young galadriel is
played by the swedish morphin clark
about a casting of celeborn nothing is
known yet elrond must also be part of
the cast in this period the lord of
rivendell will be played by robert
aramaio we already know him in his role
as the young eddard stark from game of
thrones another important elf of this
time is the high king gilgalad he is
king of the noldor the same elven race
to which galadriel belongs gilgalad is
played by benjamin walker who some of
you might know from marvel's jessica
jones two other confirmed elven
characters are muriel and aaron dear
unfortunately not much is known about
their roles yet but aaron dear can at
least already be spotted in the first
trailers and teasers he is played by
ishmael cruz cordova who so far has
mostly had small roles in series like
the mandalorian and the undoing muriel
is portrayed by cynthia robinson who has
also mostly played small roles up to now
the most famous person in the series
might be isseldore his legacy goes back
to the old movies it is the young human
prince after all who cuts the one ring
from soren's finger at mount doom in the
series he's played by max baldry the
movie makers have also created a sister
for him named ierian she is played by
emma horvath her father ellen dale will
of course be featured as well and he
will be portrayed by lloyd owen the last
lord of andui escaped the downfall of
the human kingdom numenor with his sons
after its last king arfarzan fell to
sauron and his rings of power farazan
will naturally also feature in the
series indeed it was him who opened the
way for sauron and his rings to reach
mankind in the series the character is
played by tristan gravel who will also
see the king's son kevin played by leon
waddum however the character is not
canon and was created specifically for
the new series so we really do not have
much information about him among men
there are more characters which do not
originate from tolkien for example we
have the young brown from the land of
herod which at that time was situated
between gondor and mordor browwing gets
played by nazanin boniotti in the new
series another is hal brand also a human
however not much is known about his
lineage yet the actor who plays him is
charlie vickers
to complete the last alliance we still
need the dwarves here the known cast is
not as big as for the other two races
the best known dwarf nevertheless is
during the fourth he was the king of
moria when the balrog was awakened there
in the series however he is not yet king
but still a prince the aspiring ruler of
khazad dam is played by owen arthur
while durian has a son named nayan in
the books in the series the creators
give him a daughter named diesa instead
this daughter is played by sophia nomvet
other members of the dwarf race are
unknown at the moment
actually the hobbits are not really of
much importance in the second age
however since the little inhabitants of
the shire have grown close to the hearts
of fans they will be featured again in
the rings of power a big part will play
the brandyfoot family this family is
totally made up by the creators and does
not come from tolkien stories the family
consists of largo his wife marigold and
their daughter eleanor brandyfoot they
are played by dylan smith sarah
zuangobani and markella cavanaugh and
they are not the only hobbits we will
meet static burrows played by the
british actor sir lenny henry and poppy
proud fellow will also be present she is
an acquaintance of the brandy foots and
is played by megan richards
with so many roles to play there are of
course characters who already have a
name but about whom unfortunately little
else is known the most significant one
could be the stranger he's expected to
have an important antagonist part in the
series he'll be played by daniel weyman
we can suppose that he has at least a
human appearance he ends up in middle
earth during a meteorite impact and is
first discovered by the hobbits the last
two characters are oren and trevin
however about them nothing is known at
present their names do suggest though
that they are men they are played by
joseph mall and simon merrill's
the most important thing besides the
cast is of course the plot of the series
it will build up over at least five
seasons to provide enough attention to
all the events in the second age the
last trailer gave us some additional
material but still we cannot say with
absolute certainty what is going to
happen nevertheless the name of sauron
is already introduced in the first
season the series will probably kick off
at a time of peace after the victory
over morgoth the races think that evil
is defeated and that they can finally
live in peace and prosperity but as
stated in the trailer evil does not
sleep it waits while many kings do not
see it coming sauron is already sowing
evil in the races and plans to forge the
rings of power the races of men dwarves
and elves are far too busy with
themselves to see the disaster coming
only galadriel appears to suspect it by
looking into a palantir she will try to
form an alliance against sauron another
plot line will surely be the story
around the people of numenor and how
they evolve likewise we will get to see
the riders of the rihorim the ancestors
of rohan we will thus see all sorts of
new and already known peoples but we
doubt that the first season will end in
a big battle the makers will surely save
this for the later seasons at the end of
the trailer you can see a ball rock
whether it is the balrog from moria we
do not know yet judging by the official
story it would be too early for him to
appear though the footage released so
far was definitely able to appease many
critics who were somewhat skeptical
after the first teasers work on the
second season is already underway this
gives us hope that we won't have to wait
too long for the sequel
just as with peter jackson's trilogy
they chose beautiful new zealand as the
shooting location unfortunately as with
many other productions not everything
ran well due to the pandemic in the
meantime filming had to be paused so
that up to 800 crew members had to be
sent home and production came to a halt
for weeks for a project that is supposed
to cost over a billion us dollars as it
is this is of course no small matter
luckily however production was resumed
as quickly as possible as continuing in
full swing by the way the large scale
project is not filmed chronologically
rather multiple scenes are shot very
efficiently at a single location of
course this is only possible if the
script for season 1 is completely done
since with this type of production it is
extremely difficult and costly to
reshoot scenes later season two however
means saying goodbye to new zealand as
it will be produced in great britain the
responsible parties behind the camera
are john d payne and patrick mckay who
both serve as series developers and are
the creative minds behind the project
the director responsible for at least
the first two episodes was juan antonio
baiona known from jurassic world 2. in
the subsequent episodes it is wayne yep
along with charlotte branstrom who take
over the directing who definitely will
not be returning is peter jackson who
refused to take a leading position in
the production he is only to be
available as an advisor what will also
be of interest to fans is the previously
mentioned budget after all with the
calculated 1 billion us dollars the lord
of the rings series will become the most
expensive series production of all times
the filming rights alone are said to
have cost 250 million dollars not to
mention the huge budget for season one
which is said to amount to 465 million
dollars however amazon will no doubt be
receiving a generous contribution from
the new zealand government as the
streaming giant is entitled to an
estimated 116 million us dollars from a
national film subsidy fund as a result
of the locally generated jobs
was all the info about the new lord of
the rings series the rings of power we
can hardly wait to finally experience
new stories from middle earth what are
you most looking forward to what do you
think will happen in the first season
let us know in the comments and if you
like this video feel free to give it a
thumbs up if you haven't seen the
trailers yet you can of course catch up
on them on our channel
[Music]
you